j'accueille jean leguay
allez
bonsoir belle arrivée et moi sa main
quand ça fait huit ans que je me gare
aux parkings et voilà qu'on vient pas là
tu n'es pas jean-luc la grande
différence tord le cou ce moto monde
petit pot moto
elle est belle et plus fort que leo qui
piquait de moto garée vient mon bébé
bien non
on peut pas descendre davantage
comme une cm que d'une moto comme ça
2300 denis dolly de 3 2 litres à sepang
bécane de creamer salle avantage parce
que souvent les les motos sont encore au
centac voir celle là est resté très
discret c'est comme jean-luc ouais comme
un sac aux étudiants de florence sais
pas il a piqué jean-luc bonsoir vous
voici donc de retour dans cette émission
alors depuis la dernière fois que vous
êtes venus ici et jean luc lahaye que
s'est il passé dans votre vie combien de
perquisitions combien d'arrestations
combien d'accusation de trafic de drogue
de bezons qui ont des teintes maintenant
les acteurs se sont remué s'est calmé ma
carrure et c'est réglé la wii u un
dernier petit prince est du tout c'est
fini une histoire de braquage rien
histoire de un article de journal qui a
pas plu à quelqu'un alors vous allez
demander votre boîte de nuit
oui et c'est vrai qu'en faisant le
ménage les mecs ont trouvé dans la boîte
de quoi faire gagné sept fois le tour de
france lance armstrong c'est vrai
c'était pas c'était pas du tout dans
cette discothèque 1
les propriétaires sont plusieurs à
sachez qu'on plusieurs boîtes de nuit
dans paris ouais donc maintenant c'est
fini vous touchez plus à la drogue j'ai
jamais touché un vrai nom mais là on y
mettait directement en touche pas à ça
vous tue c'est plus aux mineurs çà
aurait obligé de paraître beau champion
comme je te parle d'une chanson
maintenant ça sent très plaisir à merde
alors vous revenez avec un dvd intitulé
jean-luc là et à l'olympia et voilà non
sérieusement en fait donc concert du 8
septembre 2005 qui a marqué vos
retrouvailles avec le public après 17
ans d'absence
dix sept ans d'absence à paris j'ai fait
des centaines de tourner deux rumeurs 0
17 ans d'absence c'est pour ça que
c'était tellement émouvant quoi bah oui
et il fait passer leurs amis alors il ya
un dvd magnifique maison avec josh le
concert deux heures de spectacle au
parloir bravo deux heures de spectacle
dans cinq points communs avec la grille
comme jean michel jarre déjà même
coiffure des ouais vous avez pas ne
pariez ovo n'ont qu'à regarder dans les
cinq ans alors il ya un menu ce avec des
répètes des coulisses des clips enfin
c'est bien et puis alors avec chaque dvd
il ya un extra
c'est bon ça alors on va regarder à quoi
ça ressemble à nefta si tu savais pas
dire vous allez